foreign
in Washington DC what's up Lauren
hey Dr John how are you good how are you
doing thanks for dealing with our
technical issues how we doing
okay I was calling today because
order and
um have had a lot of issues running up
credit cards in the past during manic
episodes but the past two years I've
been episode free was able to pay off
all the debt and I'm on baby steps four
five and six now but there's still this
undercurrent of anxiety that I'm going
to do that again in the future and ruin
my finances again so I'm wondering what
advice you may have about that yeah you
bet let's um number one like before even
dig in I'm
what you just said I hope you know this
I've seen it's incredible what you just
said
it's incredible it's very rare for me to
talk to somebody in this in this uh on
the phone like this they call into the
show uh who write into the show
that there's that they've been diagnosed
with bipolar they're living with it and
then they go on to pay off all their for
years
that's amazing
it's really really incredible it's a
testament to how hard you're working on
all this
um bipolar one or two
uh two two so
um
tell me about not the manic phases tell
me about the dark phases
sometimes when it's really bad difficult
for me to
function at work and difficult for me to
get out the house and do the things I
normally like to do like hang out with
friends and
um just normal activities that I would
usually find fun are draining yeah so
for everybody listening bipolar is is
can be bipolar one or bipolar two
bipolar two is generally noted as
hypomanic meaning the Mania stage the
the the parts when everything spins up
may not be quite as high as bipolar one
but
um it's often
partnered with a deeper or a more
Sinister if you will
um depressive episode
and when people who don't experience
depression Lauren hear phrases like
depressive episode it just is like ah
whatever can you paint a picture of
waking up when you're in the black hole
if you think back to those times are you
on meds now
I I am medicated but very minimally like
much less than what most people with my
diagnosis are medicated with I I want to
applaud you for that too
one of the biggest challenges of loving
and caring and walking alongside folks
who struggle with bipolars that when
they when they feel well they feel
amazing and they slowly will stop taking
their meds or they'll completely stop
taking them and then they end up right
back where they were and so for you high
five
high five I mean you're like you're just
like rock star in this thing
um think back to some times before you
had everything leveled out
give us a description of what it feels
like to open your eyes in those mornings
wow
well usually
the first thing that I'll think of is
just that I wish I could go back to
sleep I don't want to do this
um just very low energy even if
I drink coffee it's just
feels like my body is heavier than it
usually is hard to talk to people I'm
usually
more fun to be around and people enjoy
hanging out with me and I can usually
tell when I'm in those depressive spaces
that people aren't enjoying my presence
as much
I've heard it described as feeling like
you're trapped inside of a pillow
or trapped underwater and people trying
to talk to you and everything's a little
bit fuzzy it's just exhausting and I
just would rather not not be trying to
listen to what you're saying and hear
what you're saying and interact with you
the lights feel like they're too bright
like everything just feels like too much
and
yeah it's that you used a word I've
heard often heavy it's just like
everything feels like I'm just full of
sand right yeah
and
you have worked your butt off to be
where you are
right now it's incredible so tell me
about this anxiety that's that's
haunting you
well even though I'm doing pretty good
I'll
um I think the Mania is more what I'm
scared of because the depression I've
become accustomed to the Mania I really
felt outside of myself and acted in ways
that I never act when I'm in my normal
state of mind so even though I've have
you know a good emergency fund
um
if I get too excited about something or
sometimes it gets to like any sort of
happy emotion there will be a thought
that comes in later like oh well is this
Mania are you about to have another
episode are you gonna
spend all your money again and uh
horrible situations your skin and the
environment all the time
because you've lost trust in your body
and you're wondering when uh are we
going are we going are we going no no no
no that was just too much caffeine or uh
here we go here we go oh no that was
just because I was annoyed and so it's
hard to decipher what are
and I hate to use this kind of language
but it's we just got a short time
together normal feelings right of anger
frustration excitement or I'm really
jazzed up versus oh no my body's
spinning up and we're gonna spin three
or four days
or a week or two weeks just running and
gunning and running and gunning right
and so you live in this kind of tension
you don't wanna do you feel find
yourself de-escalating things on purpose
to try to keep your body what do you
mean by that
um if you feel really excited about
something and then all of a sudden
you're talking really fast and your
friends are laughing really hard and you
cut it's you for it right it feels
awesome and you're going and going do
you find yourself trying to throttle it
back because you're scared of your own
body yeah yeah yes definitely ah and
then you end up right like yeah yeah you
end up duct taping over like normal life
experiences which are awesome and
there's nothing better than being around
a bunch of friends and you're all
hanging out and everyone starts laughing
so hard milk's coming out your eyeballs
and your nose and everything
Ah that's frustrating all right so
the good news is
um you are a
unique yet rock star example
of somebody who's
fought through hell and back
who's working with a medical
professional who's doing what you got to
do even when you don't feel like it
and who is working hard to be in tune
with your own body that sets you apart
and I need you to hear me say I'm so
proud of you it's amazing
okay what that tells me is you have at
least turned the corner on
I'm trying to live with Lauren I'm not
I'm not going to war with her anymore
is that fair
yes that tells me you love Lauren which
is awesome
okay
so I mean I just want you to drop your
shoulders it's really incredible and I
also know it's frustrating because
you're like I don't like to feel like
this all the time though and if you're
telling me I'm doing great and this is
great I don't like that
I want you to lean on it okay it's
amazing second thing is here's the not
good news
um it's gonna take time
to learn to continue to trust your body
it's just a process of trust trust trust
and then you're going to have mishaps
there's gonna be times when your body
spins out on you again and you're gonna
have to learn to be really graceful with
yourself
and then here's the important part
you're gonna have to build really strong
boundaries
what does that look like I don't have
bipolar too
there has been Seasons when I gave up my
debit cards to my wife
I got rid of the my Amazon login
because I was out of control
and I could talk to myself all day long
like all right dude we're just gonna
and I I just would buy everything
and what though I would buy stupid like
I would pick up the tab for people I
didn't even know I'd be like I'm buying
that guy's a lot like it just gets out
it's almost out of body right doesn't
make any sense and I don't have bipolar
too I'm not dealing with you're you're
talking you're on jet fuel here
so I literally had to give stuff away
sometimes it was for a month or two like
I had to just create some significant
space Here's the word I want you to
think of hurdles
what are some ways I can put hurdles
between me and these behaviors that I
know are going to cause me problems
um if you're if you had in one of in
manic phases if you had a lot of sexual
acting out which is a common thing in
both one and two
I might tell you to I want you to delete
all of the phone numbers in your cell
phone oh folks you have hooked up with
before it's delete all of them
and at least make it hard for yourself
to have to you'd have to go through a
bunch of Hoops to track it down and my
hope is at some point you have enough
cognition to go um
oh or at least I'm gonna reach out to
somebody and say hey I'm I'm trying to
do what I can to find people so if you
struggled with
um
uh binge eating I would tell you get all
the junk out of the house
right so I want you to create a whole
bunch of hurdles between you and
yourself and it may be as much as
calling the bank
and saying
I can only spend this much
at a time unless I call you specifically
will that be a pain on a day-to-day
basis yeah but will that keep you from
waking up one week and weekend and
realizing you just drained all your
savings yeah that'd be awesome too
that makes sense
yeah I like I like the idea of hurdles
okay I think barriers in place to
protect give me an example of one that
you think you could put in your life
right now
I think I can
call my parents
um
and
have them have access to
my my bank information I have that
relationship I can do that with my dad
he would
he would be a good barrier to put in
place I think it'd be pretty amazing if
you sat down with your dad how do you
learn
29 29 dude that's you're so amazing I I
think it would be great if you sat down
with your dad and said Dad I'm about to
be 30. I'm entering into a new phase of
adulthood and I'm creating boundaries in
my life because this is this is right
I'm gonna live with this forever and I'm
continuing continuing to get healthier
and healthier
um but I want some accountability that's
the magic word would you
um be my accountability person when it
came to money
and if you have a trusting relationship
like that with him that would be
incredible Lauren
be amazing and you also have a job to do
and that is to find one or two friends
in your life that you could develop that
friendship and cultivate that
relationship with them over time
that they could be that person for for
you because your dad won't always be
there
um and I've got a couple of buddies my
buddy Craig
my buddy Todd a buddy John like those
guys are close friends my buddy can like
I asked them money questions I trust
them with all I have
and
um if I'm getting out of control or
being ridiculous those are guys that
will step in and be like whoa what are
you doing what are you doing and so
um they don't all have access to my
checking account of course
um but I do allow them to hold me
accountable on these things so
um I think it's it's and maybe your dad
you know what your dad would probably
give you some great perspective too
probably provide some great like
insights into if you said Dad I'd love
some accountability if he said hey the
bank has this mechanism that if you need
to spend more than 1500 bucks at a given
time or more than 500 at a given time
um I it requires a second person or a
text message and an authorization code
or something put in some barriers for
yourself and I want you to know this
just because you have bipolar two that
doesn't mean you're insane everybody I
know who is successful has barriers and
uh boundaries and accountability in
their life I don't know anybody who runs
Reckless
you were talking about the baby steps
that's um that's inside baseball lingo
for folks who are trying to get out of
debt and following the great Dave
Ramsey's plan Dave still runs expenses
by his wife they hold each other
accountable and hey I want to buy this
we're not buying that I want to buy that
we're not buying that they still hold
each other accountable still has that
still has that
guys got more money than he's beyond
beyond comprehension
but he still has accountability in his
life
um I still have
Lane Norton and Sal DiStefano and I
still got Jordan science I got these
guys in my life that I talked to about
nutrition I talked about working out I
need boundaries I gotta get some help I
gotta get some wisdom I gotta get some
insight I gotta put some things in my
house I can't have gummy candy in the
house because I'll eat all of it all the
time so I just don't have it in there
that's not a function of bipolar one or
two that's that's a function of being a
disciplined person and knowing yourself
well enough to know what level of
discipline and accountability and
hurdles in my life do I need to be
successful the goal isn't to like become
so hardcore I don't need hurdles I think
that's a waste of time and energy
it's to know which hurdles do I need and
where do I need them in what areas of my
life and who can I rely on to hold me
accountable in those Seasons that to me
that's that is a Cornerstone of a
well-lived life that's why you hear me
always talking about connection
connection you got to make friends you
got to make friends that's why you gotta
have people in your life they call you
out
and for those of us who struggle making
friends sometimes and that might be a
counselor might be a minister that might
be a mentor where you work
but get people in your life Lauren I
need to say one more time so proud of
you
I'm so proud of you you give light and
hope to everybody struggling with
bipolar
like okay I can get on a medication
routine I can take care of my body and
get some people in my life I can start
making some decisions I can pay off my
debts I can make amends and
um have a relationship with my dad my
family amazing amazing I'm so proud of
you Lauren you call anytime I'm here for
you thanks everybody we'll be right back